Salut tout le monde!
Scream fléchettes t'as flippé!
Que faire quand on n'a pas d'inspiration ?
Les amis, c'est habituellement moi qui vous fait rire...
J’espère
:/ lol
Aujourd'hui, on va inverser les rôles tout en faisant la moulinette
et c'est vous qui aller me faire marrer!
Je vous ai demandé sur twitter de faire une petite vidéo pour me faire marrer
et je vais les regarder avec vous.
Ça va s’appeler "La Vidéo Facile"
Ok on commence avec Yann.
Oh p*tain, merci Yannou d'avoir pensé à moi !
Je te met au défi de me battre. Celui qui reste le plus longtemps sans cligner des yeux.
*T'es prêt ? Un, deux, trois.*
*Musique épic *
(Cri)
(pleure)
J'suis nul de ouf à ce jeu!
Ah je chiale ça m'a tué les yeux!
Mais arrête Yann! Mais cligne des yeux!
Mais Yann tu vas crever !!
C'est pas moi qui irais t'acheter le produit à lentilles pour hydrater les yeux derrière.
Attend mais c'est en pause la vidéo ? (rires)
Mais Yann!
Attends j'ai le temps de refaire le challenge et de re-perdre avant lui!
Try Hard #2
(Cri)
Yann: Je sais t'avais demandé une vidéo courte mais bon... Là je tient.
Mais mec mais c'est pas ça ! Le problème c'est que je chiale! Tu m'a fait chialer !!
Yann: Bon j'pense que t'as cligné ...J'pense que j'peut... J'peut arrêter.
Nan, nan, nan !
Oh t'as perdu Yann. Ah ah !
Yann: Abonnez vous hein!
*Placement de produit moche, signé Yann.*
Eh eh !
Ah Yann!
Tu m'as fait pleurer devant mes abonnés!
Je vais appeler cette vidéo "Je pleure devant mes abonnés"
Merci Yann !
Grâce à toi, j'ai le titre et la miniature !
(Tête bizarre)
Ouais, je faisais la pose pour la miniature. (Rire)
Ne vous enflammez pas, j'ai dû arrêter avant. Mon record : 3mn12
Le mec se chronomètre quand même, bon... (rire)
On en est là !
Bon, au suivant !
Mdr
(bruits de langue)
C'est très malaisant..., c'est très très malaisant...
Oh la la, qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Il y a un chat, ça me plaît.
(bruit flippant)
(rire)
(pouffe de rire)
On en est là !
Monsieur Alison, on en est là !
Encore un chat ? Mais arrêtez avec vos chats, p*tain !
(bruits de machine)
Non ! Mais non ! Mais ça c'est vilain !
Na jamais caresser son chat après ça. Jamais.
(Rire)
Tiens !
INSTANT KARMA !
Tu fais pas chier un chat !
(Rire)
C'est quoi ça ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ??
Ce que tu fais...
C'est quoi ça...
(bruit de casse)
Et il revient...
éteint la caméra...
Mais pourquoi ??
Mais je t'ai pas demandé de t'ouvrir le front, mec,
sur.. sur un truc dans lequel on est censé pisser...
(Bruit de contact)
Simple, efficace,...
Très bien !
Je m'abonne !
"Je vais essayer de faire crier ma maman !"
(bruit de casse)
(Ehhhh)
"Voila !"
(pouffe de rire)
Mais moi, je suis ta mère, garçon,
mais je viens,
je dois avoir un corps de...
Ne dis pas ce mot !
(cri de fighter)
Ca, c'est pour faire exprès de me faire crier !
P*tain,  mec, ma mère m'aurait décapité pour avoir fait ça.
OK suivant...
Ouhh ! 255 RT...
"Eh, tu sais que aujourd'hui, tu vois, c'est l'anniversaire de Mimi Mathy...
"et tu sais quel âge elle aujourd'hui ? Elle a 52 ans."
"Bon, bref, on s'en fout un peu, tu vois..."
Ouais !
"Eh ben, on l'a pas vu grandir..."
Des grosses barres...
Mister MV qui nous fait une vidéo....
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça... (cri flippant)
P*TAIN !
"Continuez à liker, et abonnez-vous...
Toujours de bons conseils, ce Mister MV !
(Musique angoissante)
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH !!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH !!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
OK, suivant !
"Rires"
"Rire gras"
Ah ! Le beau rire de sagouin...
(Rire effrayant)
Ah ! J'adore les chutes comme ça...
ou... en douceur,
bien en finesse,
c'est gentil d'être tombé pour moi...
Et je parle pas de la prison...
Ahahahah, énorme !
Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Super Kiwi, dis moi...
Ouais, il y a marqué Squeezie...
Tu inspectes, tu es très très fort en informatique...
Tu changes, tu as marqué un truc, euh... mature, je suppose...
Ouiiiii !
Et maintenant, tu as....
... prout, ouais !
Bravo !
(cling)
Ah ! Tu vois, j'ai reçu un SMS en même temps....
Ta chaîne Youtube a été bannie pour avoir diffusé un vine aussi pourri...
eh ben voila !
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça , là ?
Qu'est-ce que vous faites à vos animaux ?
"Musique de Da Ba Dee "*rire*
Quand cette famille est venue me chercher dans mon élevage,
à côté de mes frères et soeurs,
j'étais heureux !
Je voulais vivre avec eux.
Mais en réalité, chaque jour, je dois danser pendant plus de 10 mn,
pour divertir mes maîtres !
Sais-tu faire ça ?
"Denzel Curry - Ultimate "
Ah, le Bottle Water Flip !
J'ai jamais essayé, j'ai jamais essayé...
Mec, attention, on va rétablir la vérité...
POOOOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
C'est le premier de ma vie, mon pote, j'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie !
Attends, je peux te le faire sans regarder...
WOUAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Oh p*tain, c'est super marrant à faire, j'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie....
Bon, voila...
Je préfèrerais faire l'amour...
OK, on passe à la suite !
Fais une meilleure thug life que moi.
C'est quoi ça ?
Ne posez rien sur cette table...
"Musique gangsta"
Il a posé un vieux truc flingué, mon gars!
Il a posé le plus petit truc du monde, quoi,
tu sais, une carte SD !
Le mec, c'est un thug mais pas trop !
Quand ta soeur adore Jul...
(bruit de frappe)
(pouffe de rire)
Comment percer sur Youtube ? Astuce en vidéo
Tu fais bien de le dire...
"Coucou les copains ! Bienvenue pour une nouvelle vidéo !"
"Et comme vous avez pu le voir dans le titre,"
"je vais vous apprendre à percer sur Youtube."
Ahhhh !
(bruit de perceuse)
Je sais pas quoi dire.
Est-ce qu'on est pas à un niveau 1 du jeu de mot, là ?
HEIN ?
Non, non, non... c'était...
Non, tu perces, arrête, ahhh,
t'as maintenant plus d'abonnés qu'Amixem, arrête !!
Ahhh, il nous a doublé !
N'est-ce pas le visage d'un homme fier de sa blague ?
Si !
C'est la première fois que je réussi, dont ce rire de merde.
(bruit d'impact)
"Ohhhhh, j'ai réussi, hi hi hi !"
(bruit de bouteille qui tombe)
On aura tenté !
Bon, c'est quoi ça ? Non ! Un mec a moitié à poil avec une poubelle,
c'est jamais bon.
"C'est parti pour le poubelle flip !"
(bruit)
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
(Musique épique)
(bruit de fracas)"La Pauvre il va devoir aller à Ikea :/" R.I.P La chaise de SQUEEZIE ! On t'aimait :(
*Le visage de la honte*
*Qu'est ce que je fous de ma vie*
Abonnez vous pour sauver ma dignité.
Pourquoi me défiez-vous avec vos challenges de m*rde ?
Eh voilà, les amis, (charabia)
Non, je me prend pour David Lafarge.
J'ai foiré mon challenge, mais vous avez réussi, vous m'avez fait rire,
ca m'a fait du bien !
A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien, tcho tout le monde !!
Peace.... shh shhh...
*Musique*